I think we should be
collect
about how we create
greater sense of community and I mean
that both at home from perspective
thinking locally but also thinking
globally you know from the moment we
wake up by the time we are out of our
home headed to work or school we are
indebted to half the world from the
coffee we drink that may have been you
know grown in Latin America or Africa
she was sponge that we may have used
that was created by or captured by a
Pacific Islander we don't having a
synthetic sponge to the tea that we may
have had that may have been produced
someplace in Asia to the clothing that
we may wear that will have likely been
produced in some part of the world and
in so many other ways we are so
interdependent but I think that one of
our challenges at home and thinking both
at home and around the world is a sense
of community it is about more of the we
and less than to me because in thinking
of the we we will achieve more for the
me but you know I think we need to be
thinking about how do we create greater
senses of community and how do we work
individually to make that community more
that sense of community Beloved
Community more of a reality and I think
that's something that would serve as
well and whether and whether that's back
at home and wherever we call home or in
the state or the country where we live
in a sense of that community or in a
sense within this more global community
of which I believe so strongly we are so
two related it is working to create a
sense of a community and thinking more
about we than just about the me
you